la région métropolitaine de Montréal a
perdu de sa densité au cours des 20
dernières années résultat moins de
personnes occupent désormais un plus
grand espace en zone urbaine à la place
d'avoir trois salles de bains est-ce
qu'on peut en mettre deux un qui répond
aux objectifs du rez-de-chaussée et en
bas qui me Parisot et son équipe
d'architectes tant de s'attaquer à
l'étalement urbain en revisitant le
modèle de maison unifamiliale on doit
prendre notre petite maison puis venir
faire un multi générationnel on veut
avoir autant de picorer on veut vivre
dans du Grand au Québec on veut avoir
accès à la nature mais on veut pas trop
trop non plus on veut pas trop
d'entretien vu que ça dure longtemps on
veut de la qualité mais densifier ne
voudrait pas nécessairement dire la
construction de tout raconter les unes
sur les autres selon l'organisme vivre
en ville si on regarde ici un peu à
gauche ça commence à être un peu un peu
costaud mais on a également fait de la
maison de ville juste ici on a du 3-4
étages jusqu'ici on s'est ancré autour
un parc à caractère patrimonial ici
c'est la gare d'ausi
l'idée aurait d'ailleurs mis quelques
années à germer avant d'être accepté
dans certains quartiers de Montréal
puis que c'était uniforme etc mais
lorsqu'on vient y ajouter des parcs
lorsque les arbres deviennent matures
lorsque le temps fait son œuvre ça
arrive assez souvent que ça s'améliore
je comprends très bien les gens qui
veulent pas vivre dans ces tours-là pour
le chroniqueur Olivier il faut rendre
les villes plus attractives l'idée c'est
de c'est de rendre ces tours là à 12
étages ou à moins plus agréable pour que
les gens disent peut-être que si
j'habite dans un quartier plus dense ou
une belle qualité de vie mes enfants
sont voir à l'école au coin de la rue il
y a des commerces de proximité je peux
aller par mes courses à pied il y a des
parcs pas envie d'aller vivre en
banlieue éloigné juste pour avoir leur
grande cause alors que Québec a déposé
en juin dernier sa première politique
nationale de l'architecture et de
l'aménagement du territoire
qui a mis la densification au cœur de sa
stratégie c'est les attentes sont
grandes les résultats eux se font
attendre ici Gabriel prout Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]